一筋の光が
私を切りされているこんにちははじめ社長です
まぶしファイトクリームですね地獄が12:40お昼の12時40分です外はしっかり
新しいです
うざ実は僕さんですね今日ほぼ寝てなくて私時からの撮影だって超寝不足状態なんです
よ
多分名爪ではもう
me
今のはわざとですね結構の上段だけで横になると秒でんでるぐらいでもいいですね今で
そんな状態なんですけども
寝ると起きなきゃいけないじゃないですかで起きる時って目覚まし時計とか
静かな状況でデカイ音あっってならすってばっ
何か起きるんですけどもそれとは逆に常に音が鳴っている状態としましょうね何が車の
音が鳴っている状態でいまだがでれる
思うんですよ常に音が鳴っている状態店裂蹄てるよりずっと大人っているんですけども
突然パ
突然パって音が止まった時ってそれもそれで起きるんじゃないかなってなんで
目覚まし時計の人が起きるよと言いますと姉別にうるさくて起きるんじゃなくて寝る
ことができた状況がずっと続いて突然超極ガーンで彼は着点大きいと思うんですよと
なっているので僕が出るとその音楽ありきの状態が僕が出る状況なんですよ音がないと
いけない状態
突然音がピタッと止まる止めてる僕も
あって起きるのではないかという実験をやってみようと思いますもしこれが成功すると
いうの中の目覚まし時計著書変わりますために音が鳴ってる目覚まし時計でおきたい
世界に設定して音が止まるそんなことマジであり得ると思うんですよ
かもよ漸減まずは音楽から作りましょうねもう脱ぎが静か過ぎても泊まった時わかん
ないと思うんで
程よくほどよく起きてられたなきゃ
がいいなぁ
おっ
いやもう本当に眠いん瀬尾やばいすっっ
ん
あこれぐらいどうですか
[音楽]
全然寝るこれぐらいでれますこれで流れてるんですけども突然
起きると思うこんだけ環境からとまずで起きると思うんですよ
この音楽を使ってまず音楽を作ります
様子を上げできました時で基本的にこのこのなんかいかにも寝れそうな音楽が流れるん
ですけども突然
突然このんですが
[音楽]
停まりますいやこの環境の変化はさすがに違和感を覚えて起きると思うんですよ
これはかなり気になる実験だと思いますでは早速 os ビルズ
うううう
じゃあちょっとゾーンで切れてますおやすみなさいん
ん
本当にあるからねあちょうど4だけだとりあえずこのなんかないといけないぐらいの
気持ちになろうと
薄れるぞおやすみー
京王
ua
[音楽]
me
うって
今ので分かったと思うが人は大きな音ないと落ちてしまう生き物なのだい
だか今から人間の常識を覆すような大発見が行われようとしている
[音楽]
全世界よ刮目せよ
夫が止まる瞬間をザンッ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
[音楽]
[笑い]
ねっす撮る度になるなぁ
当時取るのに音楽なんだ